- [Envy] Now, how far are
you from buying the Jets?
- I think I'm very
far and very close.
So let me explain.
I love patience.
I got a lot of things
in place on third base that
I haven't cashed in on.
There's a lot of things I can
do if tomorrow it has to happen.
Call in (mimics phone ringing),
call in all those favors,
cash in all those chips.
Sell all the, you know,
my company just did a huge
transaction that valued
the company at a $400 million
valuation that puts my
net worth at $200 million of
what I own of that.
I've got all this paper money on
Facebook I can cash it all in.
It's on the stock market.
I've got private money in
Uber and other things that I can
convert to somebody else.
I've got pieces but
Woody's not selling
and the truth is I don't
have the $2.7 billion.
I'm nowhere close to that.
Now, and I don't want to go
round up a lot of
people to be a partner.
I want to run shit.
I need to win a Super Bowl.
So the good news
is he's still young.
You know, I wish him
health every single day.
I would love to have another
15 to 20 years to make the play.
But the truth is, Envy, the
journey to try to buy them,
that's the game.
- [Envy] That's the game.